[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Voldemort
peeling back the layers of his character
and clearing up some misconceptions in
the Magical World of Harry Potter love
plays a pivotal role in shaping the
lives of his characters often serving as
a powerful force that triumphs over
Darkness at the center of this Darkness
stands Lord Voldemort a figure
synonymous with evil and the antithesis
of love a man thought to be incapable of
such an emotion but what if I told you
that it's actually a lot more
complicated than that what if I told you
that Voldemort's inability to feel love
was actually a massive
oversimplification that shrouds the
intricate details lying underneath
and now for the best part what if I told
you that what I'm talking about is
confirmed by Canon if you like me wish
to develop a deeper understanding of
Harry Potter's most infamous villain
learning things about him that are
widely overlooked then sit back relax
and enjoy as we dive into the true
motivations of Vaude Voldemort it all
started at the beginning Voldemort's
mother maripi gaunt later maripi riddle
was a purebred wedge that hailed from
the house of gaunt with a long dark
history known details of the gaunt
family can be traced back as far as the
1600s the family was known for many
things the first being that they were
descendants of the famous Wizards
Salazar setherin and Cadmus beverel the
second being their absolute obsession
with blood Purity in fact in an effort
to keep their bloodline pure the gaunts
began marrying their own family members
which of course resulted in centuries of
inbreeding the family was at one time
wealthy and prominent a prosperous
Wizarding family that reaped the
benefits of being around during the
formation of The Wizarding World As We
Know It but over time the gaunts became
poorer more inbred and well a disaster
in whichever way you looked at them and
by the time marapi came into existence
the gaunt family were reduced to living
in little rundown Shack just outside the
town of Little Angleton engulfed in
poverty and obscurity born in 1907
therapy ensured quite a difficult
upbringing in the town of Little
Angleton sharing the family home with
her father marvolo and brother Morphin
from the moment she was born maripu
faced a troubled existence constantly
berated and abused by her father and
brother however in adulthood marapi
finally found herself alone for the
first time this was following an
altercation between her brother father
and the ministry of magic Morphin was a
mentally deranged wizard that liked to
use Magic on Muggles something that
ultimately led to many conflicts between
his family and the ministry of magic
following one of these attacks Bob Ogden
from the ministry's magical law
enforcement Squad visited the gaunts
prompting violent resistance from the
gaunt men during this altercation
Morphin revealed marapi's romantic
interest in a muggle from their town
which prompted marvolo to attack her
Ogden intervened attempting to protect
marapi but this only caused Morphin to
jump in and attack Ogden the Fiasco
ultimately led to both gaunt men being
arrested and sent to Azkaban with
marvolo being sent away for six months
and Morphin for three years finding
herself alone for the first time in her
life marapi was finally able to exercise
her magical abilities abilities which
had always been suppressed through the
torment of a brother and father
with this newfound Freedom it didn't
take long for her magic to flourish
however these Newfound magical abilities
eventually manifested in the form of a
love potion also known as amortencia
embleton shares the most powerful love
potion in the world it is distinctive
for its mother of pearl Sheen and steam
rises from the potion in spirals a
mortensia smells different to each
person according to what attracts them
amortencia is considered by some to be
the most dangerous potion in the Harry
Potter universe as it doesn't even
induce actual love just a semblance of
love that is derived from strong
Obsession this potion can truly make
people do some very uncharacteristically
strange things and what did therapy do
with this love potion why use it on the
wealthy handsome muggle Tom Riddle
senior of course it's unknown how
exactly maripi gave riddle the Love
Potion as their lives weren't
particularly intertwined but we do know
that he fell under its spell quickly
becoming infatuated with marapi fast
forward just a few months later the two
were married and marapi was pregnant
with Tom's child Tom marvola Riddle this
child would later go on to become Lord
Voldemort far fast forward a year and
suddenly the effects of the spell no
longer seem to be influencing Tom it's
unclear why this may have happened but
there are a few prevailing theories the
first is that narapi perpetuated her
brainwashing of Tom via the imperious
curse and that she eventually stopped
because she was curious as to whether he
may have genuinely fallen in love with
her the second is that the effects of
the Love Potion simply wore off
regardless of what may have happened
when Tom was no longer Bewitched it
didn't take long for him to abandon his
wife and son promptly heading back to
the town of little hangleton after he
fled Murphy fell into a deep depression
and stopped using magic entirely and on
New Year's Eve in 1926 she went to an
orphanage and gave birth to her son Tom
marvola Riddle Tom for the boy's father
and marvolo for therapy's father marapi
died shortly after riddle was born as at
this point she had suffered immensely
from a broken heart merapi effectively
chose to die as she had no will to live
and because she was not there to give
Tom love and care he grew up without any
concept or notion of love it was
originally implied that one of the main
reasons that Voldemort can't feel love
is because of the way that he was
conceived because his mother and father
didn't genuinely love each other and
because his father was under the
influence of a love potion he was born
with an incapability of feeling it an
adventure to say this is how nearly all
all Harry Potter fans have perceived
Voldemort's inability to feel love but
this is what most people get wrong as
there's actually a caveat to all of this
you see most people deduced from the
tragic tale of Voldemort's birth that he
is fundamentally incapable of love it
turns out that's not actually the case
in an interview from many years ago JK
Rowling introduces the possibility for
Voldemort to feel love suggesting that
Heap is capable it's just very difficult
for him how much does the fact that
Voldemort was conceived under a love
potion have to do with his inability to
understand love is it more symbolic it
was a symbolic way of showing that he
came from a Loveless Union but of course
everything would have changed if marapi
had survived and raised him herself and
loved him in this interview Rowling
reveals that if therapy had been there
to raise him then he could have loved
what this means is that he's not as
emotionally incapable as other Canon may
suggest and honestly even though therapy
wasn't around to raise Voldemort I've
always kind of thought that Voldemort
loved nagini at least a tiny bit but
with this new information comes a whole
barrage of other questions and
implications if Voldemort was in fact
capable of understanding love no matter
how specific the context what is the
true nature of his evil this information
challenges the notion that his lack of
Love is what makes him so villainous and
to me this sort of undermines his
character additionally if Voldemort were
capable of love it would add a layer of
complexity to his character that may
potentially evoke empathy or sympathy
which complicates perceptions of him as
an irredeemable villain furthermore the
notion that Voldemort is capable of
feeling love disrupts the broader theme
of Love In The Wizarding World in Harry
Potter love is a powerful force often
portrayed as a strength that can triumph
over evil Lily Potter's loving sacrifice
is the single greatest example of how
powerful love can be
if Voldemort were capable of
experiencing love it could challenge the
idea that love is an inherently positive
and redeeming quality this forces a
reevaluation of the series themes and
the role that love plays in the battle
against Voldemort in addition to what
I've mentioned above Voldemort being
capable of Love also opens up the
following considerations
humanization the ability to love would
humanize Voldemort making him a more
complex and multi-dimensional character
this could lead to a deeper exploration
of his motivations desires and emotional
struggles Furthermore with the knowledge
that Voldemort was in fact capable of
Love readers and fans may find
themselves re-evaluating his actions
throughout the series leading to a more
nuanced understanding of his decisions
alternative storylines if Voldemort had
the capacity to love it opens up the
possibility of alternative storylines
and character arcs could his ability to
laugh has led him to Redemption how
would this impact other characters in
the story I've spent a fair bit of time
responding to comments on this topic in
the past so hopefully this clears up any
sort of confusion and that's it for
today what do you think about this
uncovered aspect of Voldemort's
character does it enhance the story or
work against it be sure to check out the
channel on Spotify and also take a look
at my extra Channel where I post three
additional videos per week until next
time remember to have been loved so
deeply even though the person who loved
us is gone will give us some protection
forever